[Applause]
he has and you have to make him put the
ball down on the floor and play into
traffic you cannot allow him to just
step into rhythm shots great time by
wiggins inside for looney
[Applause]
tatum lost it behind him peyton dives
for it
and here comes clay thompson
wiggins nice sidestep and finish
wiggins with his second field goal
smart against curry and curry with the
two foul smart throws it back deflected
by thompson here's wiggins wiggins down
the lane and the flush curry the rebound
well the celtics will know that better
than anyone they've been so many
momentum swings in these playoffs since
wiggins
nobody in front of him goes down throws
it down
11 points for wiggins
smart throws it away that's eight
turnovers now for boston curry catches
fires scores
start slowing the game down
trying to milk the clock wiggins swats
it out of bounds
as white went to the bucket back up top
wiggins drives on horford spins up and
under
porter launches a contestant shot it's
good otto porter nails it
it's a two-point game
how about the fight
of this warrior basketball team otto
porter with the clock dwindling down
good contest not good enough
tops in a porter
porter kicks it out wiggins gets a great
look and knocks it down
wiggins has 16 and it's back to eight
[Applause]
hooked away by wiggins
thompson ahead and wiggins throws it
down
wiggins
posting up white
[Applause]
nice turnaround jumper wiggins off to an
excellent start he's got eight points on
the pull-up comes up short boy short
wiggins the rebound
[Applause]
wiggins pushes goes right at tatum euro
step lamp is good
i just think when you're a star
you run back you try to block the shot
but you don't foul unnecessarily
wiggins makes his move falling away jump
was good
and a chance for a three-point play
boy it's scary how good you are knowing
the game of basketball you called on
wiggins being aggressive and he responds
gets the hoop and the contact going to
the line for the possible three-point
play we will you just look at the lineup
iguodala hasn't played much and that's
not really his game peyton's not a he's
a defender
final at 24. wiggins against white
that's a difficult turnout wiggins makes
it look easy
looney
curry back to wiggins wiggins goes
inside laugh is good
gorgeous move from andrew wiggins
wiggins drives and finishes
exclamation point from andrew wiggins
has gotten his opportunity and has taken
full advantage of it it's not how you
drive is how you arrive
mama there goes that man
[Applause]
158 remaining the warriors the
championship dna shows up
five out of 24. white given the open
look now drives on wiggins the runner
blocked by wiggins kept alive stolen by
peyton you fall in love with the way
that pool is started knocking down shots
but draymond green is making plays all
over the floor another turnover cool
pushes finds wiggins wiggins throws it
down
smart looking to post a pool peyton
looking to help bad pass deflected by
thompson and another steal
wiggins inside the payne and payton
throws it down the turnover is once
again costly for boston